wird es reichen frau wagenknecht noch
mal es gibt ein großes
investitionsprogramm es gibt ein großes
hilfsprogramm insgesamt für die
wirtschaft wird es reichen um dafür zu
sorgen dass wir tatsächlich die
wirtschaft auch umstrukturieren sie
haben das vorhin angesprochen herr
altmaier von otto wird es uns gelingen
in diese tech industrien in die it in
die ki industrien hinein zu kommen und
das zeitgleich na ja das problem ist
dass wir jetzt viele jahre verschlafen
haben weil die regierung eben in ihrer
marktgläubigkeit auf eine konsistente
industriepolitik völlig verzichtet hat
über all die jahre auch die übrigens das
war ja eher geächtet also dass man
industriepolitik macht und jetzt
selektiv zu sagen wir wir stützen
bestimmte unternehmen die teilweise auch
eben wegen ihres investitionsverhaltens
jetzt in einer misere sind halte ich für
problematisch also leiche wäre doch
jetzt dass beispielsweise die ganze
autoindustrie ich meine die haben so
viele gelder nicht die stütz milliardär
selbstverständlich schon allein das
kurzarbeitergeld ist natürlich eine
staatliche stützung seines für jeden
aber es wird in diesem jahr überwiegend
aus steuergeldern bezahlt das
kurzarbeitergeld und ich finde schon
wenn unternehmen wie vw in diesem jahr
die dividende sogar noch erhöhen
bmw schüttelt eine dicke dividende aus
allein zwei leute das geschwisterpaar
quandt und glatten kriegen 770 millionen
mitten in der krise da kann man doch
sagen von diesem geld allein von diesen
770 millionen hätten sie die gehälter
ihrer kurzarbeiter problemlos bezahlen
könnte das heißt wir subventionieren
ihnen direkt dividendenzahlung und das
halte ich für falsch und ich finde auch
falsch dass wir nicht eine klare ansage
an die unternehmen haben wer in der
krise noch aktien zurückkauft und
dividenden ausschüttet der kriegt dann
auch keine staatliche unterstützung wenn
es schwieriger wird weil sie hat
natürlich eine reihe von unternehmen
staatlich gestützt die noch anfang des
jahres dividenden ausgeschüttet haben
tui zum beispiel oder adidas hat in den
letzten jahren seine anleger verwöhnt
mit riesigen ausschüttungen und dann
natürlich keine reserven in der krise
es kandidieren die stellen das
kurzarbeitergeld gilt für alle nicht an
unternehmen gezahlt das wird an die
arbeitnehmerinnen und arbeitnehmer
gezahlt an die 10.000 mitarbeiterinnen
von vw und von anderen unternehmen ob
sie groß oder klein sind damit diese
menschen ihren arbeitsplatz behalten und
ich glaube die verantwortung hat dass es
eben auch bei den schwächeren und bei
denen die sich nicht helfen können nicht
zu großen brüchen und verwerfungen kommt
und im übrigen wir haben klare
regelungen wenn es stützungsmaßnahmen
gibt für unternehmen
dann dürfen keine dividenden gezahlt
werden aber wir müssen die vorstände
einschnitte bei ihren vergütungen
hinnehmen und zwar ab dem zeitpunkt
natürlich wo wir helfen wenn ein
unternehmen zu einem zeitpunkt wo es
noch gar keine einschränkungen durch
corona gab dividenden ausgezahlt hat
dann kann das kein grund dafür sein dass
wir die arbeitsplätze jetzt vor die
hunde gehen lassen und sagen du bekommst
von uns keine unterstützung und keine
hilfe aber wem geholfen wird der muss
mit seinem geld wenn man sein kind noch
nicht mal jetzt das festgelegt sie haben
noch nicht mal für jetzt für die krise
ich meine wir haben in deutschland
wieder dieses jahr eine rekord
ausschüttung also 34 milliarden allein
bei den dax konzern das ist eine summe
die mit der wirtschaftlichen lage in
keinem verhältnis
gleichzeitig knausern sie bei kleinen
unternehmen bei solo selbstständigen bei
freiberuflern die wirklich ohne eigene
schuld in nöte kommen da wird nichts
gespitzt und es wäre auch
konjunkturpolitisch natürlich sinnvoll
die kaufkraft vor allem bei denen zu
stützen die eigentlich gar nicht viel
geld haben weil die haben jetzt wirklich
existenzielle ängste die haben teilweise
mehr schulden und dann sagen sie hat sie
sollen konsumieren letztens im bundestag
wurde geworben geht konsumieren das ist
ein hohen gegenüber menschen die jetzt
wirklich massiv einkommen verloren haben
und denen sie überhaupt nicht helfen
wagen rechten stunde ist es völlig
falsch was sie sagen ein unternehmen den
wir helfen auch keine dividenden
ausschütten
und diejenigen die die rekord
ausschüttungen machen dass in
unternehmen die ohne staatliche hilfen
durch die krise kommen wie zum teil
gewinne machen und die ein teil der
gewinne an ihre aktionäre und an ihre
mitarbeiter weiter geben das ist
verfassungsrecht nicht verbirgt das
können wir
war schon corona hat noch im märz aktien
zurückgekauft und unmittelbar etwas
später festgestellt jetzt wird es doch
eng
also brauchen wir alle und sein und dann
wenn es hilfe gibt dann wird festgelegt
dass keine dividenden ausgeschüttet
werden dürfen und dass das geld verwandt
werden muss um das eigene unternehmen
und alles in der wie die frage noch
einmal für unser verständnis wie groß
ist die gefahr dass wenn unternehmen
keine dividenden mehr auszahlen
das dann auch übernahmekandidaten so
entstehen das ist natürlich eine gefahr
aber ich würde sagen man kann diese zwei
systeme zum beispiel deutschland usa gar
nicht vergleichen hier ist es vielleicht
einen designfehler wäre das natürlich
sehr schwierig ist das so ganz gezielt
alles auszugestalten in amerika gehört
es mehr absichtlich zum design dass wir
frau wagenknecht anfangs sagte das
natürlich viele große viele millionäre
und sogar milliardäre von den
hilfsgeldern abgesahnt haben
und wenn wir uns jetzt nochmal anschauen
wie die wirtschaftliche situation in
amerika ist die großen konzerne die
schon angesprochen waren
sie sind nicht nur wertvoller als
europäische konzerne sondern sie sind
natürlich auch wesentlich profitabler
und bauen ihren ausspruch ihren
vorsprung momentan aus machen sie das in
dieser krise tatsächlich wieder so ihr
absolut also zum beispiel den größten
teil des dow jones des amerikanischen
aktienindex machen die fangen aktien aus
das sind die fünf größten wie amazon
google netflix und so weiter die
gewinnen immer mehr hinzu die
profitieren ja auch von der krise weil
jetzt alle von zu hause arbeiten immer
mehr leute verlassen sich auf tag und
die stellen aber am wenigsten leute ein
asiate und größten prophet bei den
wenigsten arbeitnehmer
wir sind wenn ich vielleicht noch dazu
sein dürfte weil auch immer gefragt wird
warum reform der aktienmarkt so gut und
donald trump das immer so hält man muss
auch sehen dass ein prozent der
amerikaner 50 prozent des wertes des
aktienmarktes halten und zehn prozent 19
prozent der amerikaner sind der
reichsten 90 prozent des wertes das
heißt dass der großteil der amerikaner
von dieser guten börsenperformance
überhaupt nicht profitiert wir sind noch
mal bei einer frage an den virologen
herr strikt wenn das virus einmal außer
kontrolle
gibt es dann eigentlich die möglichkeit
es wieder unter kontrolle zu bekommen
also die sorge und diese zweite welle
die die ist in den usa momentan viel
größer als hierzulande und in europa
aber ist es möglich gibt ja keine
kontakt nachverfolgung mehr ist es
möglich dieses virus dann wieder unter
kontrolle zu kriegen
naja ich glaube wir müssen uns von
diesem gedanken verabschieden dass wir
das virus irgendwie komplett austreiben
können aus der gesellschaft ist es da
das wird auch bleiben und das wird teil
von unserem alltag werden und wir müssen
anfangen souveränen damit umzugehen und
ich rechne damit dass es eine zweite
dritte welle geben wird wir haben so ein
dauerndes auf und ab war waren wie wir
das für alle coronaviren kennen am
besten können wir so ein virus eindämmen
wenn wir wissen wo es den tipp wo die
infektionen sind in dem man dort gezielt
testet was die bundesregierung ja auch
macht und dann auch kontakte nach
verfolgt in gütersloh war ein
wunderbares beispiel wie gut das
funktioniert hat das war schon sehr
lokale ausbruch aber mit solchen
hotspots werden wir immer wieder rechnen
müssen und dann auch dass dort dann
eingedämmt ja und dann noch mal der
blick auf die welt wenn also in
verschiedenen teilen der welt dieses
virus immer noch herrscht können wir uns
dann über unsere guten zahlen freuen und
wir es nutzen sie also ist es sehr
wahrscheinlich dass auch ein virus über
landesgrenzen kommen kann
die diskussion habe jetzt das eine land
besser ist als das andere ist ein
bisschen müßig weil das virus ist ja
nicht politisch aber es ist irgendwie
politisch in der diskussion geworden was
mich besorgt macht ist die stellung der
vero ich hoffe dass die wer hier
wirklich gestärkt raus kommt aus dieser
krise ist zeigt dass es eine globale
pandemie ist dass es nicht halt macht
vor den grenzen und das wir eigentlich
eine zentral gesteuerte eingreiftruppe
braucht die eben diese hotspots
eindämmen kann
jedes mal wenn man in so ein hotspot
reingeht lernt man das virus kennen
lernt man die ausbreitung kennen und man
es gibt so ein gewachsenes wissen
darüber was man gar nicht nieder
schreibt und auch in deutschland würde
ich mir das wünschen dass es da
wirklich einfach gezielte gruppe
reingeht robert-koch-institut deutsche
rote kreuz reingeht eindämmt und mit
ihrem wissen und ihr mit der stärke dann
immer weiter wächst und immer besser
daran so das ist noch mal der blick auf
die welt frau wagenknecht das was donald
trump mit seinen handelskriegen nicht
schafft erledigt dann in manchen teilen
der welt offensichtlich dieses virus
muss man ja zynisch sagen wo ist
sozusagen in diesem kampf jetzt zwischen
den usa und china die position europas
wie können wir schaffen gegen diese
wirtschaftliche rezession und
gleichzeitig gegen das virus erfolgreich
zu sein
ich finde europa muss stärker seine
eigenen interessen sehen also was donald
trump jetzt seit jahren macht und
wirklich mit einer enormen aggressivität
ist ja einfach die interessen seiner
volkswirtschaft seiner unternehmen zu
vertreten in einem wirklich auch ganz
offen einen handelskrieg also viele
maßnahmen jetzt die jüngsten sind ja zum
beispiel gegen nord stream mit den
sanktionen aber auch vorher schon die
aufkündigung des iran abkommens auch
sanktionen die russland sanktionen das
sind ja alles maßnahmen die europa und
auch ganz konkret der deutschen
wirtschaft schaden weil das sind
wichtige märkte für uns größere oder
kleinere aber es sind märkte die wo die
deutsche wirtschaft durchaus gute
geschäfte gemacht hat und er zerstört
die ganz bewusst und ich finde dass wir
da also wirklich auch gucken müssen wie
wir eigenständiger werden auch wie wir
unabhängiger werden ich sehe zb mit
großer sorge unserer abhängigkeit in der
wichtigsten zukunftstechnologien nämlich
in dem digitalbereich also die die
großen plattformen sind alles
unternehmen aus den usa und das heißt
dass unsere ganzen daten alles was wir
machen
das baut dann sozusagen auf diesen
plattformen auf aber letztlich fließt es
dahin das heißt alles was wir tun auch
was unseren unternehmen tun gerade wenn
jetzt viele dinge auch eben zb online
laufen dass wir dort in der cloud
gespeichert in den usa ausgewertet es
gibt eine ganz enge liaison zwischen
diesen silicon valley unternehmen und
den amerikanischen geheimdiensten das
heißt das ist bedrohlich und dann müssen
wir eigenständig werden unabhängig
werden und da würde ich mir wirklich
weit mehr politische initiativen
wünschen als diese ständige überwachung
von allen bürgern und bürgern so
hinzuziehung dazu gedacht er altmaier
gleich etwas ich möchte gerade gerne
frau david wird noch mal um ihre
expertise bitten frau blieb diese die
tech giganten sind angesprochen die
setzen die standards die setzen die
regeln und sie wehren sich auch
erfolgreich gegen eine besteuerung ist
das noch marktwirtschaft oder ist das
schon geopolitik was würden sie sagen
vielleicht sollten wir erst mal
klarstellen ich denke in deutschland man
sieht interesse immer mit so eine
wirtschaftliche blick sanktionen gegen
russland und eine harte kurs gegen china
macht die usa aber das ist auch gut für
die stabilität von poly welt und am
erker macht die schmutzige
sicherheitsarbeit und deutschland
profitiert davon natürlich manche sagen
der viele sagen der ton und ort von
donald trump ist aber am sanktionen
gegen russland ist auch war auch war
auch die vorband das war auch unter
präsident obama und tencel marco ist die
stärkste und unterstützer von diesem
markt maßnahmen
gottseidank und amir europa musste ich
einigen auch in sachen von technorati
zum beispiel das ist wichtig aber beide
europa ist manchmal auch gespalten und
normalerweise die usa ist wichtig vor
einem einigte europa leider haben wir
ein präsident zur zeit der nicht die am
eu respektiert aber ich kann ihnen sagen
ob amerikaner abgeordnete die ich kenne
von beide parteien sehen die werte von
mozilla tourismus und auch die eu und
auch nachts zum beispiel den tag fragen
ja ein land hat viele innovationskräfte
und ich denke nicht dass firmen wie
google und microsoft nur die daten an
die us regierung schicken
sie sind auch involviert auch die
privatsphäre zu schützen aber sie wollen
geld verdienen
wir haben einen wirtschaft ein free
marktwirtschaft in den usa das ist gut
so sie haben monika schnitzer vorhin
zugehört ich will die frage nicht
vergessen
sie sagt sie völlig zu recht dass es
einen großen internationalen wettbewerb
um die klügsten köpfe gibt um die
wissenschaftler oben die facharbeiter
glauben sie dass europa zukünftig davon
wirklich profitieren kann und vorteile
haben könnte wenn donald trump da jetzt
einfach die schotten dicht macht
internationale studenten visa verbot und
so frau david liebt es war noch eine
frage an sie können sie natürlich um die
besten köpfe ich wollte bei ihm bleiben
kampf um die besten köpfe
wissenschaftler facharbeiter kann europa
glauben sie wie frau schnitt er sagt
dass profitieren
vielleicht vielleicht aber ich bin froh
dass meine eltern aus indien
ausgewandert sind und sie haben die usa
gewährt und ich würde sagen immer noch
zu arm einwanderer dass man kann nahm
die amerikanische traum in der märker
leben aber wir müssen das system
reformieren
wir brauchen das wort zugang zur
gesundheitsversorgung wir brauchen mehr
am gleichheit und ende von rassismus und
diskriminierung
um dieses amerikanische traum wieder zu
leben deutschland kann versuchen
natürlich die beste kräfte und ich denke
deutschland hat steht sehr gut da die
führungsrolle von deutschland ist wieder
da sie müssen etwas etwas dazu machen
oder damit machen so und dann sind wir
bei der politischen diskussion herr
altmaier interessanterweise hat sich
wolfgang schäuble zu wort gemeldet der
ist jetzt nicht bekannt für
umstürzlerische ideen aber er sagt wir
müssen die globalisierung und unsere
ganze art zu wirtschaften überdenken
und er sagt europa muss
widerstandsfähiger werden
aber wie überzeugt man und wer überzeugt
unternehmen produktionen wieder zurück
nach europa zu holen wenn es sich nicht
rechnet
das ist eine aufgabe in bestimmten
bereichen die stadt und unternehmen
gemeinsam erfüllen ich habe mich sehr
gefreut über den beitrag von frau bank
nicht eben weil genau das was sie bei
den daten kritisiert haben das tun wir
ja wir haben das projekt garics
gegründet und 300 unternehmen
arbeiten an einer souveränen
europäischen dateninfrastruktur dass die
daten eben nicht in den usa gespeichert
werden müssen
das funktioniert nur wenn staat und
wirtschaft in wirtschaft und staat
gemeinsam arbeiten wir haben es
geschafft über 60 unternehmen dazu zu
bewegen die batteriezelle produktion
aufzubauen
die modernsten die leistungsfähigsten
umweltfreundlichsten
lithium-ionen-batterien für autos und
andere ansehen aber ich will auch sagen
bei allem respekt für wolfgang schäuble
von dem ich viel gelernt habe in meiner
politischen tätigkeit wir werden die
globalisierung nicht umdrehen sie wird
nicht verschwinden
wir müssen unabhängiger werden von
einseitigen monopol müssen unabhängiger
werden
wenn lieferketten durch pandemien
irgendwo auf der welt bedroht sind ja
aber deutschland ist eines der länder in
der welt die am meisten davon für ihren
wohlstand profitiert haben dass es die
globalisierung gibt dass es weltweiten
waren und dienstleistungs austausch
geben und das wollen wir auch in zukunft
an den kanten damit die welt auch
stabiler geworden die gleiche frage aber
nochmal nach der stärkung einer
europäischen souveränität wird es
überhaupt gelingen gegen die großen it
unternehmen in amerika und wer soll hier
in europa unternehmen überzeugen
produktion zurück zu holen kann die
frage auch wieder nur wiederholen also
produktion zurück zu holen das ist
wahrscheinlich gar nicht so schwierig
weil das anschauen das produzieren vor
ort immer preiswerter wird vor allen
dingen dadurch weil die billiglohnländer
jetzt immer teurer geworden sind im lohn
und weil immer mehr maschinell
hergestellt wird das heißt sie können
eigentlich viel preiswerter jetzt auch
hier herstellen nur das bringt ein
anderes problem beziehungsweise mit
anderen worten löst das problem nicht
weil es nicht wesentlich mehr
arbeitsplätze schafft aber das ist ein
problem was wir auch schon vor bewohner
hatten und überdenken müssen und das
haben im grunde genommen alle weltweit
und natürlich sind maschinen weniger
anfällig als der mensch der mensch kann
krank werden und damit wird diese motor
der digitalisierung und der
automatisierung weiter angekurbelt
glauben sie ja weil bis jetzt war
eigentlich unser größter
wettbewerbsvorteil gegenüber maschinen
und
mensch sein also zum beispiel im
ausbildungsbereich oder medizinischen
bereich wer möchte sein todesurteil von
einem watson computer bekommen dass man
unheilbaren krebs erkrankt ist also oder
wer möchte gepflegt werden von einer
maschine
aber jetzt da hat corona donald trump
auch ins bleibt gespielt ich sag mal ist
es wie eine bio waffe die ihm in die
hand gegeben worden ist zur legitimation
und rechtfertigung weiteren
protektionismus und die maschine sierung
wird unter corona sicherlich weiter
schneller fortschreiten